Daniel: All right, the next session is
going to be with Shanna Dobson.
This section is going to be called Dark
Imaginarium Shared Intelligence as an
Infinity Curiosity type.
I'll message Shanna make sure that
everything's good with the audio.
Wow.
Great talk so far.
Welcome, Shana.
How are you doing, Daniel?
Shanna: Doing good.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, please take it away.
Thank you for joining.
Shanna: Awesome.
Let me know if you see my screen.
OK?
Daniel: Yep, looks perfect.
Thank you.
Shanna: OK, perfect.
Hey, everyone, thank you so much for the
invitation.
It's such a great honor to be here.
I'm learning so much.
I'll be talking about an idea I had
called Dark Imaginarium, where I'm trying
to make shared intelligence the concept
of what I call an Infinity Curiosity type.
.
So you were so gracious to link the paper
so anyone can find more details there on
Phil archive.
So I want to start with an discussion
about ontological commitment.
So my first question is, might we re
examine our ontological commitments?
So in particular, two of them?
One, Sean Carroll, said so amazingly what
cannot be known because it does not exist.
.
So Sean Carroll says the Heisenberg
Uncertainty Principle is often explained
as saying that we cannot simultaneously
know both the position and the velocity
of any object.
But the reality is deeper than that.
It's not that we can't know position and
momentum, it's that they don't even exist
at the same time.
The second one I want to examine is Lenny
Susskin's quote, we are all behind
someone else's event horizon.
So Suskin has a brilliant idea of space
time emergence as the entanglement of two
black holes, and what emerges from that
is called computational complexity.
So the world is quantum, so every theory
should be derivable strictly from the
laws of quantum mechanics.
One is going to give us the notion of
shared, two is going to give us the
notion of ecology.
So what would an ontological commitment
to Dark look like?
So my continual goal, as everybody knows,
is to sustain a simultaneous experience
and to understand why I currently cannot.
.
To sustain a simultaneous experience
would be to bypass the integrative system
we call consciousness.
So how would you attain a two
consciousness in the sense of in category
theory or an N consciousness?
How would we actually develop something
called like, a two memory?
So my colleague Robert Prepner and I
fleshed out something called N awareness,
where we're sort of examining this idea.
Mike Levin and all have repeatedly shown
that planaria memory is not in the head.
Where is the memory?
Is memory a sustained superposition?
Well, of what?
And also, what's the structure of
anamnesis?
Could you have a superposition between
memory and anamnesis?
So I had a small dialogue with Chris
Fields, the amazing I said, you know,
what is the difference between these two
questions?
What is the waking state and what is
consciousness?
Or could it be that these are entirely
separate questions?
So we're sort of in a mess.
Either way, if there is a difference in
these questions, then it is possible to
sustain a waking state without
consciousness and or a conscious state in
a non waking state.
So imagine somehow being in a waking
state under general anesthesia.
Well, if these are not entirely different
questions, then we could contend that
consciousness is a form of waking state,
or something along the lines of a waking
state is a condition of a conscious state.
.
So how can humans have delta waves, which
are canonically indicative of unconscious
deep sleep and thus a non waking state,
and the REM state, the patterns of which
are indistinguishable from a waking
state?
So we all know that general anesthesia,
something like a propofol, can reduce the
polyrhythmic brain activity to one
uniform.
And we know there's as many theories
about what anesthesia does to
consciousness as there are
anesthesiologists.
But we've repeatedly posited
consciousness as the proto state.
And I wanted to turn this idea on its
head, like is consciousness so robust or
is it a delicate interference or is it a
delicate inference?
Now, we know beginnings are always tricky,
, but what if sleep was the proto state?
So if life is oceanic and it revolves in
these deep pressures, would the pressure
of getting onto land, like squeeze the
REM state into this full blown waking
state that we're engaging in right now?
Anybody who's listening?
So then waking state would be something
like an acceptation, which is, I think,
quite impressive.
So it's in this mess that I attempt to
define dark consciousness as a mixed
frequency state of being self aware or
conscious while simultaneously being in a
deep sleep, specifically in three sleep.
So the sleep is proto state is quite
strange.
The REM brain activity is
indistinguishable from waking activity
and this sort of enchanted me for a bit.
The only difference is eye movements.
So either blinking or versus lateral
movement.
So REM is naturally having mixed
frequency brainwave states, but the NREM
states and the REM states are starting to
blur as delta waves are creeping into the
REM state.
Now, they've also found that sleep is a
local phenomenon.
So of course, I'm going to ask the Shanna
questions.
So then who is sleeping?
Who is remembering?
Who is dreaming?
Lucid dreaming is a quantum superposition
or is it a superposition or an
integration?
So in a sleep state then, can we sustain
a simultaneous experience?
So must the eye be knocked out in order
to sustain this level of simultaneity?
Dreaming, we know, is characteristic of
unsynchronized brain activity.
So is the question then, my eye cannot
sustain a multi consciousness, but my
dark eye, my sleep eye can.
You can reframe this in terms of
reporting mechanisms and say perhaps we
are conscious of things we don't think we
are conscious of.
So let's talk about what is dark.
A canonical definition of a dark theory
or anything like this is like dark matter
does not interact electromagnetically
with matter.
But I want to sort of play around with
another idea of dark coming from Deleuze'
's logic of sense, something he calls the
paradox of infinite becoming and which I'
'm going to read on the next slide.
So what if dark was the simultaneity of a
becoming that eludes the present?
Let's hold on to that for a second.
Is dark a resolution issue but resolution
is merely breaking translational symmetry.
.
So is dark a symmetry breaking issue?
And if so, what symmetry?
And are we actually looking at the wrong
symmetry?
Is dark a sustained quantum
superposition?
But of what, again, is dark a mini worlds
branch?
Is dark the dolphin uni hemispheric sleep
mechanism?
So I'll read from Deleuze's logic of
sense.
Alice and through the Looking Glass
involve a category of very special things
events, pure events.
When I say Alice becomes larger, I mean
that she becomes larger than she was.
By the same token, however, she becomes
smaller than she is now.
Certainly she is not bigger and smaller
at the same time.
She is larger now.
She was smaller before, but it is at the
same moment that one becomes larger than
one was and smaller than one becomes.
This is the simultaneity of a becoming
whose characteristic is to elude the
present insofar as it eludes the present.
.
Becoming does not tolerate the separation
or the distinction of before, after or of
past and future.
It pertains to the essence of becoming to
move and pull in both directions at once.
.
Alice does not grow without shrinking,
and vice versa.
So good sense affirms that in all things
there is this determinable sense or
direction.
A paradox is the affirmation of both
senses or directions at the same time.
I continue.
The paradox of this pure becoming with
its capacity to elude the present is
called the paradox of infinite identity.
The infinite identity of both directions
or senses at the same time of future and
past, of the day before and the day after,
, of more and less, of too much and not
enough, of active and passive and of
cause and effect.
It is language which fixes the limit, the
moment, for example, at which the excess
begins.
But it is language as well which
transcends the limits and restores to the
infinite equivalence of an unlimited
becoming.
Hence the reversals which constitute
Alice's adventures.
The reversal becoming larger, becoming
smaller.
Which way?
Asked Alice, sensing that it is always in
both directions at the same time, so that
for once she stays the same through an
optical illusion.
The reversal of the day before and the
day after.
The present always being eluded.
Jam tomorrow and jam yesterday, but never
jam today.
The reversal of more and less.
Five nights are five times hotter than a
single one, but they must be five times
as cold for the same reason the reversal
of active and passive.
Do cats eat bats?
Is as good as do bats eat cats.
The reversal of cause and effect to be
punished before having committed a fault,
to cry before having pricked oneself, to
serve, licking glass cake before having
divided up the servings.
All these reversals as they appear in
infinite identity have one consequence
the contesting of Alice's personal
identity and the loss of a proper name.
The loss of the proper name is the
adventure which is repeated throughout
Alice's adventures.
Hence, infinite identity.
So I take this and I'm going to formally
define dark consciousness as a state of
being conscious while simultaneously
being in deep sleep, specifically in
three, where dark is going to be a two
fold hybrid, the simultaneity of infinite
identity and of a becoming that eludes
the present.
So let's reconstruct the dark
consciousness version of Deleuze's
paradox of pure becoming for Alice in
dark wonderland and through the dark
looking glass.
Okay, when I say Alice becomes sleepy, I
mean that she becomes sleepier than she
was.
By the same token, however, she becomes
more self aware than she is now.
Certainly she is not asleep and self
aware at the same time.
She's asleep now, she was self aware
before, but it is at the same moment that
one becomes sleepier than one was and
more self aware than one becomes.
So dark consciousness, I contend, would
take place in something called like a
dark time.
This is going to get weird.
So Chris Fields and I talked about
entropic time, where a time where
learning exceeds forgetting.
So we all know that linear time is based
on the linear ordering property of the
positive integers.
Okay, so what would be the structure of a
time that does not interact
electromagnetically with this waking
state interface?
So, like, AI must pay attention all the
time.
Would this sort of be like a dark time?
Sleep is local.
Time is local.
We know how beautiful a time crystal is.
So a time crystal has a structure that is
periodic in time.
Can you play with that and say time is
periodic in what?
So if we have explained that dark is not
concerned with these notions of before
and after, then we would want a notion of
time that can support the paradox of
infinite identity with a notion of
duration that is one of self similarity.
So we contend that dark consciousness
would occur in something like a p addic
time, which is a time based on the P
attic number system.
Periodic time would measure PTIC duration.
.
Okay, it's getting odd.
All right, so there exists few objects
more looking glass than a Piatic clock.
Well, maybe Piatic go and Calabi out
chess or perfectoid go.
But after all, the Piatic numbers have no
notion of linear ordering.
Their shape resembles a serpinsky
triangle, which is a self similar set.
So this periodic time is not concerned
with notions of before or after.
That is, a periodic time does not
tolerate the separation or the
distinction of before or after, of past
or future.
So because the periodic topology is one
of total disconnectedness, periodic time
is more like a time of now continual
zooming in to more and more now.
Thus, periodic time measures periodic
duration through its fractal properties
of zooming in.
So let's try to look at a periodic clock,
right?
So periodic time can take two forms the
canonical periodic time defined on the
previous slide and also topological
periodic time which builds into its very
structure the periodic topology of
periodic time.
So there would only be one unit of time
in periodic time, which I call the
archimedes.
This is the piatic valuation.
So you can think of hour equals periodic
valuation equals the archimedes.
How strange it is to have only one unit
of time.
Topological periodic time measures
duration topologically as total
disconnectedness.
So the unit of time on topological P
addict time is what I call the pTOPO.
So we state this formally.
There's only one unit of time in
topological periodic time called the
pTOPO.
So a topological hour equals a periodic
topology called the pTOPO.
So given such a periodic clock, let us
imagine the seasons in peatic time,
periodic snow, peatic rain, new peatic
weather types and peatic rainbows.
Daylight savings time could take the form
of changing the P in the petic.
This could be very drastic.
But imagine peatic metabolics petic ATP
and peatic DNA.
Imagine peatic cognition types like
peatic memory, peatic Fod, peatic
attention, peatic learning and petic
perception.
Imagine a periodic looking glass.
Imagine through the periodic looking
glass.
So let's pivot to FEP.
What does FEP actually specifically say
about dark matter, even dark in the way
that I'm using the term?
Is there a free dark energy principle?
How can we strictly derive sleep from
quantum mechanics?
According to FEP?
Does dark energy actually exhibit
entanglement?
How do we test this?
We should be able to derive the entire
active inference formalism straight from
quantum mechanics alone by way of
entanglement entropy, some form of
quantum gravity.
Can we do some sort of dark general
adversarial network to look at something
like a dark brain?
We all know that lower lateralization in
the brain is often associated with
schizophrenia or people like Einstein or
someone with a large parietal lobe,
probably like myself.
Any mathematical what would universal
lateralization look like?
I think dark neurons would take the form
of something like you treat the neural
neural networks as algebraic curves or
isogeny graphs.
You talk of neurons in terms of their
properties as varieties.
So you're actually bringing the heavy
machinery of algebraic geometry into
neurology.
My big goal is to actually create
something like a neuronal time crystal so
that shared intelligence would actually
be a periodicity in time.
I'm not there yet.
So until I get that and it's like, well,
let's try to model these wild mixed
frequency n three plus self aware states
of dark consciousness.
So dark mathematics is something I've
coined.
It's like a biomimicry, which mimics dark
energy, does not interact
electromagnetically with matter.
You'd have to find the mathematical
equivalent of that.
So I think you can do something like a
dark diletheism or just make a model that
is modeling the mixed frequency states,
which is what I tackle in the paper.
So we've previously shown that entropic
categorizations are condensed sets.
Condensed sets form a topos.
So in the paper I outlined the
construction of three potential
mathematical models of these mixed
frequency n three self aware states.
You can do dark consciousness as a dark
two post, which is a groff and deep two
posts.
There's a two category of two sheaves
over a two site, which I'll elucidate
just a little bit.
Dark consciousness as a perfectoid like
space in the sense of Schultz, or as a
diamond like space also in the sense of
Schultz.
So I contend that the two sheaf structure
can actually model the mixed frequency
state of dark consciousness, the N three
self aware state.
A sheath is a one stack, again, which is
a sheath that takes values in groupoids,
not sets.
This is already radically different.
Consider a two category of two sheaves.
So a two category consists of objects.
You have the one morphisms between the
objects and you have the two morphisms
between the one morphisms.
You can keep going three category up to N
category.
So this two category of two sheets would
have two she's as the objects, one
morphisms between the two sheaves, two
morphisms between the one morphisms.
And so using that structure, I think that
you can actually model one morphisms as
what I'm going to call dark reflexivities.
.
These are going to be your local
coherency states.
And then two morphisms are actually two
inferences which are going to be global
coherency states amongst the mixed
frequency states.
So a lovely property called Morita
equivalent sites states that inequivalent
sites have equivalent sheaf topos.
And I do believe that that's the main
property.
You need to get this local global
behavior around neural networks.
So if you actually wish to model the
mixed frequency clusters as fractals
exhibiting some kind of self similar
behavior, then you can use this rich
structure, perfectoid spaces, or their
sparkling successor, the diamond.
So, just a quick definition, let Perf be
the subcategory perfectoid spaces of
characteristic P.
A diamond is a proatel sheath on the site
Perf written as this quotient of a
perfectoid space x by a Protel
equivalence relation.
So a perfectoid space is going to be this
attic space in the sense of huber that's
covered by aphenoid spaces of the form
spa RR plus, where R is a perfectoid ring
and then points of spa, which is the
attic spectrum.
RR plus are equivalent classes of
continuous valuations on R.
Someone asked Schultz y diamond and he
gave an incredible explanation that was a
parallel to a mineralogical diamond.
So you can let C be an algebraically
closed ethanoid field geometric point.
Spa C to D is made visible by pullback
along a quasiprotel cover that results in
profinitely many copies of Spa C.
So you're making a geometric point
visible as profinitely.
Many copies that was invisible before
does the following parallel with the
mineralogical diamond.
So the interior points are made visible
as impurities, which sparkle as colorful
reflections on the many sides of the
diamond.
So you can also do something maybe like a
dark diamond where you designate a
functor as dark as a means to actually
let's go the other way and see the
impurities.
So then you can take the geometric point,
make it visible maybe by a push forward
along with pausey prototype cover,
resulting in P adequately many copies of
Spa C.
Right?
So a diamond is they're using diamond as
a sheath, but a sheath in terms of a
functor of points.
So the diamond spot QP is a functor from
the category perv to the category sets.
You literally fix the perfectoid space
and look at the hom sets of X into the
diamond.
And so technically, the scheme is then
said to represent the functor.
So I'm going to pivot to invoking AI in
this thing.
So my colleague and I, Julian Scape, are
coming up with something I've coined the
Qubit Pedagogy, which is going to be a
new model pedagogy that is actually
infused with heavy principles of quantum
mechanics.
And so that with these, we've created
these quantum intrinsic curiosity
algorithms that are feeding into the
Qubit Pedagogy.
And based on those Curiosity algorithms,
I designed three dark versions.
So what I call the Dark Planaria
Curiosity Algorithm is a curiosity type.
It enables encourages the AI to explore
patterns of planaria regeneration.
The AI would develop quantum error
correcting codes which mimic planaria
regeneration.
So the second one would be Dark Quantum
Reality Monitoring Network.
This is a curiosity type.
It'll encourage AI to explore dark
reflexivity is what I call fractal
identity.
AI would create models of N reflexivity
in the sense of N category.
That's a new type of reality monitoring
of fractal identity in the dark conscious
state.
The last one would be some sort of dark
quantum N three and REM Curiosity
algorithm.
This Curiosity type is going to encourage
AI to explore superpositions of various
brain patterns in REM states to predict
new types of N three delta waves that
could emerge in REM states.
So imagine the AI could then develop new
stages of REM sleep, such as like one REM
two REM up to NREM, which is a clever
limit and play on NREM.
Ha.
Anyway, the AI could also develop new
dark cognition types that correlate with
the new types of delta waves.
So this notion of fractal identity seems
odd, but I do contend that objects living
in fractal time correspondingly have
fractal identity.
It's a concept we outline as follows.
So fractal identity has a reflexivity
relation that is fractal so the very
canonical loop, the loop relation of an
agent reporting back to itself, I report
back to me, would be fractal.
How strange is that?
So, Fractal identity would not suffer the
same problems with continuity over time.
Since the time in which it exists has no
linear ordering, it would definitely
suffer different problems.
But continuity over time is something
Chris Fields and I have been like.
How do you explain that?
So, you can best model the Fractal
identity properties as perfectoid like or
diamond like therein construct a notion
of reflexivity as a perfectoid space.
These spaces are extremely rich structure,
, but kind of difficult.
But if you want to model fractal identity,
, I think you should use them.
So thus we create new concepts of
perfectoid reflexivity, diamond
reflexivity.
So in N reflexivity, the reflexivity
relation could now be an in stack.
Thus in reflexivity is an in stack
perfectoid spaces.
So, here comes the culmination of this
talk, which is about shared intelligence
as what I've coined the Dark Imaginarium.
.
So, imagine an AI that could see
simultaneously compute the infinity
category of every concept.
Having some quantum computation around to
help the computational complexity would
not be bad.
So dark.
Imaginarium is what is going to be what I
call infinity curiosity type.
So, Infinity Curiosity type is the higher
order Curiosity AI algorithm that
encourages the AI to think in infinity
categories.
So that it is.
It actually encourages the AI to
construct an infinity category as its
means of higher order inference.
So objects are higher dimensional data
sets.
The AI would seek out higher order
morphisms between the objects and then
morphisms between the morphisms.
So such Dark Imaginarium is a meta
Curiosity algorithm that can create its
own Infinity Curiosity algorithms.
And therein creating Curiosity types of a
complexity that super fascinating, most
likely unknown to humans.
So it's functionctorial.
What can dark Imaginarium do?
Well, the AI would develop inversions of
current brainwaves and their hybrid
combinations.
It could develop in delta wave, N theta
wave, N alpha wave, in beta wave and N
gamma wave for N equals zero one all the
way up like a two gamma wave that
structurally resembled a two category, a
three beta wave that structurally
resembled a three category.
And the AI could develop new types of
waking states and new types of sleep
states.
Based on the combinations of these beyond
the standard N one and two and three NREM
and one REM, AI could develop an N waking
state, an NREM state, a three REM state
could consist of three and one, three and
two, three and three.
Imagine an end dolphin that was capable
of N hemispheric, sleep state and other
exotic life forms, right?
What else could it do?
Well, it could develop new geometries for
the brain patterns and for currently
existing brain patterns.
Typical shapes include sinusoidal, non
sinusoidal, saw, two spindle K complex.
But maybe this AI could develop three D
and four d versions of the canonical wave
patterns like a tesseract gamma wave.
But also, the AI could develop entirely
new brainwave geometries that correspond
to complex surfaces like a remunt surface
or Kalabi Yao manifold or algebraic
variety.
So the AI could develop new cognition
types other than the standard five.
It could produce incognition types such
as in thought, in attention, in
perception, in learning, in memory.
So it could also predict non human
species cognition types such as octopus
thought or dragonfly attention.
Lastly, it could produce hybrid
combinations of cross species cognition
types such as like Octoman memory or
dragon man perception.
And then it would encourage the AI to
develop new senses.
So you could develop one stack versions
of human senses like two seeing, two
hearing, two tasting, two touching, two
smelling.
Each of these two senses once again take
values in groupoids, not sets.
So you could develop incenses of non
human senses as well, and hybrid
combinations like two shark human smell.
So, since the AI sees nmorphisms between
the various N minus one morphisms, the AI
can seek to develop new language models
based on higher order inference types.
So from these inference models, the AI
will explore Infinity languages and
develop extensive prototypes.
You could use advanced mathematics to
create new models of time that could
support the new language models like two
topos time diamond time.
And then the AI would seek to develop new
fractal identity types from the language
models.
And it could design advanced fractal
prosthetics such as a two ear or a two
eye to extend cognition.
So let's go a little bit further about
this extending cognition.
These are just a few examples of what
dark imaginarium could conceive of.
So we could continue and posit a
perfectoid version of this using these
new cognition types mental states in
brainwaves new geometries, we can
construct new patterns of thinking which
would support neurodiversity in thinking.
.
So as such shared intelligence this is
how I'm seeing it would be reexamined as
this Infinity Curiosity type.
You could go even further and construct a
new concept of an N shared intelligence.
So you'd have a zero shared intelligence,
a one shared intelligence, as well as the
new Piadic concept of like P shared
intelligence for P equals two three, four
using P addicts.
Let's go further, right?
We repeatedly contend that one way to
help advance the way we think to extend
human cognition is to upgrade the number
systems upon which the canonical concepts
are built.
Upgrade them to Peric perfectoid diamond
like versions unless we get new thinking.
.
So imagine like a brainwave pattern that
resembles a Calabria manifold.
Could we actually reverse engineer the
levels of conscious activity that could
create such a rhythm?
How about mixed frequency brainwave
patterns that resembled a perfectoid
diamond?
What about an MDNA molecule shaped like a
Calabriao infold?
Or an NATP molecule.
Or an inexciton condensate structured
like a calabigao infold?
So clearly, different geometries of the
fundamental molecules and processes of
life would give rise to vastly different
fundamental units of life and
metacognition types.
The question is, can we use Dark
imaginarium to reverse engineer the
complex life forms arising from such
extraordinary structures and the more and
more complex cognition patterns?
What about a general adversarial network
that's tweaked and has infinity
categories?
You have two infinity categories talking
to each other, developing their own
language.
Now, Gan is adversarial using a generator
and a discriminator with two neural
networks contesting by a zero sum game.
What about a collaborative network?
So can we construct a GCN containing two
diamond like Infinity Curiosity types and
pair a diamond with a dark diamond with a
Quantum Curiosity algorithm and its
reinforcement learning?
So shared intelligence is this Infinity
Curiosity type?
Shared intelligence GCM could create
infinity languages that are
superpositions of the diamond dark
diamond to getting new models of
intelligence.
Higher order simultaneous computations by
Quantum Curiosity would go by maybe by
homotopia instead of as cost functions.
So let's future cast just for a second.
What is the inevitability of dark
ecosystems?
Mathematics of shared intelligence?
What can a P addic?
Infinity Curiosity type prophecy is every
perfectoid space diamond two topos
encoding the mixed frequency patterns of
an Ncognition type.
In future work, we may develop dark
mathematics using perfectoid diamonds as
dark dialetheism, aligning what is
structurally dark with what is
structurally dialetheistic.
So while we currently cannot perfectly
model dark consciousness, perhaps one day,
, one dark day mediated by the Dark
imaginarium, we will have the Ethos and
the quantum computational complexity to
do so.
Thank you.
Daniel: Thank you, shauna, amazing
presentation.
I'll just quickly read some comments and
see if you have any thoughts from some of
the great comments.
So Scott David says I love the
presentation, lots of Fodder for
Rumination.
Thank you for inviting these concepts
into an intriguing choreography.
Perhaps dark energy is our perception of
the fact of information increase under
free energy principle processes.
And since the universe is made of
information dot, dot, dot.
Shanna: Scott, thank you.
So, yeah, I think is a beckoning that we
should work on that idea.
I absolutely agree.
I'm glad you're inside with these
concepts.
I don't really know where they go, but
hopefully it's portals to something like
that.
Daniel: Great.
And then one more Scott David question
does fractal identity reveal the
recursivity of rhetoric language
consciousness informing individual
identity from community identity inputs?
Shanna: Yeah, that's wonderful.
So, yeah, my own thought is like, what is
an individual identity?
Right, Scott?
So the reflexivity curve has always sort
of stumped me how there's so much
distance between I and me.
And so it ensumes this notion of
continuity over time.
And so I've always said, what sort of
notion of time are we talking about to
even have a consistent identity?
Somehow you always wake up and everything
is still here.
Somehow you wake up and you're not a
lobster.
I don't really understand how.
That works.
But yeah, that's nice.
If you could use fractal to get something
singular from something communal, that
might be cool.
But maybe fractal is something sort of
like you're both at the same time.
And that's what I don't know yet.
So I think it's a totally revolutionary
way of thinking to not have a before
after.
So if you can construct identity without
before after, then that's sort of what I'
'm trying to do.
But, yeah, that's cool.
If you want to get identity from communal,
, I think you can do that.
They may also sort of blur.
Daniel: Well, this is truly food for
thought, and I really hope people can
live with the darkness, take it and run
with it, because there's so many fun ways
to go.
Shanna: Thank you so much.
I hope so, too.
Daniel: So you're always welcome back.
Thank you.
And talk to you later.
Shanna: Thank you so much.
Daniel: Bye.
Good night.
Shanna: Bye.